[Music]
joe biden was elected as a moderate who
was going to stay the course return
this country to normalcy it turns out
biden is
changing the united states faster than
any president ever has
in american history our job on this show
is to pay attention to exactly
how joe biden is changing it the new
york times isn't going to tell you
we think you have a right to know now
not every change that joe biden makes
will matter over time despite all the
huffing and puffing a lot of things that
presidents do are quickly forgotten some
of the things joe biden promises
won't happen others are just symbolic
ring kissing
designed to appease the interest groups
that got him elected
but some of biden's changes are very
real
and they matter very much nothing
matters more than what joe biden does to
our u.s military
our military is the last functional
institution of any size in this country
it's the last institution most people
trust and respect
it is by far the most important a weak
military means
no country period so on monday when we
saw joe biden pledge to bring a quote
intensity of purpose and mission to
really change the culture and habits of
the us military
we paid attention to it here's what
biden said
some of it's relatively straightforward
work
where we're making good progress
designing body armor that
fits women properly tailoring combat
uniforms
for women creating maternity flight
suits and
updating updating requirements for their
hairstyles creating
maternity flight suits maybe those suits
have been around for a while we'd never
heard of them but here was the president
of the united states
promoting them at a press conference and
that phrase stuck out
not because we have some hateful bias
against pregnant women flying military
jets
we're pro-pregnancy as we often say
we're also open-minded
maybe pregnant women make the best
pilots the department of defense
measures
everything so there's got to be
extensive research on this question
if the pentagon can show that pregnant
pilots are the best we will be the first
to demand
an entire air force of pregnant pilots
the problem is we're pretty confident
that joe biden hasn't asked to see those
numbers
we'd bet money that joe biden never even
thought to ask
the rest of us depend on the us military
to protect our families and protect the
country itself
but joe biden doesn't see it that way
finding the most
effective military pilots or infantry
officers or seal teams
is not his priority it's not even close
to his priority
identity politics is joe biden's
priority it's all that matters
you see this attitude throughout the us
government as well as in the corporate
world
key positions filled on the basis of
physical appearance
without any reference to ability or
experience
now you can get by with that if your
citibank which now cares more about
wokeness than about banking
they can explain the results to their
shareholders 10 years from now
but it is not fine if your only job is
to protect the united states from people
who want to kill the rest
of us that is the worst kind of
dereliction of duty
yet it's happening right now on an
enormous scale just this week the bite
administration announced that the
pentagon will pay for gender
reassignment surgery for active duty
personnel
how do sex changes in the military make
this country safer
it's not a trick question it's not
another volley in the culture war
it's the only question that matters
literally the only question that matters
but no one bothered to ask it probably
because no one can remember
why the us military exists here's a
reminder
the u.s military exists to fight and win
wars
that's its only purpose the us military
is not an
ngo it is not a vehicle for achieving
equity it's not a social
experiment it's definitely not an
employment agency
nobody has a god-given right to work in
the military no one does and that
includes
all of us if you ever hear this show
whine that delta force is discriminating
against paunchy 51 year old cable news
hosts
you'll know that we have lost the thread
because it's not about us it's about the
country
making people feel valued and included
is a good thing
it is not the point of the us military
it cannot be the point of the us
military or else we're done
now that used to be obvious the military
was the purest meritocracy that we had
if you get a minute go back and listen
to some of the speeches that colin
powell used to give about his experience
in the us army
the military was willing to judge colin
powell purely on his talents something
that few would do at the time
powell was smart and capable and for
that reason in the end he became
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
he was justly proud of that and so was
the country he
served would colin powell's story be
possible today
no it wouldn't joe biden has put a man
called lloyd austin in charge of the
pentagon
biden plucked austin from the cynical
world of private equity but you're not
supposed to notice that
you're supposed to notice only that
lloyd austin is black
the real headline however is that lloyd
austin is the second defense secretary
in a row to have been on the payroll of
raytheon the massive defense contractor
if you saw something like that happen in
a central american country
you would call it corruption and you
would be right
for centuries our military has been
self-consciously nonpartisan in a
democracy it has to be that way the
military has to be
non-partisan no country can survive if
its armed forces become a tool of a
specific political party
we know that because it happens all the
time all over the world
and the consequences are always
horrifying it has never happened here
but lloyd austin is openly political in
his first days on the job austin made
the entire armed services submit to a
kind of political purity test
anyone who had views that lloyd austin
found quote extreme
had to leave the rest of us watched as
this happened we saw it
once again no one said anything
the left approved the right felt
hamstrung because they support the
troops
of course if you support the troops you
probably should speak up when they're
being
abused as they were then lloyd austin
sent about accelerating poisonous trends
already
in progress at the pentagon worst of
these is the use of irrelevant criteria
in hiring and promotion
in order to meet the demands of various
democratic interest groups the pentagon
has dramatically lowered standards in
the services
now spokesman officially deny this but
it is true ask anyone who works there
if you press the spokesman they'll tell
you that it's not really a big deal
because
traditional standards don't really
measure anything
well then why have them in the first
place why have standards at all
it doesn't make sense they're lying and
they're lying because they have to lie
politicians have demanded it now if you
dare to point any of this
out they become hysterical and they
become hysterical because they can't
defend
their own policies when people can't
defend what they've done
they yell they can't even explain what
those policies are
at least in public so they attack you
hear politicians like tammy duckworth
say that it's
unpatriotic to question the pentagon
unless you have served in the military
yourself you haven't earned that right
really can only cops talk about police
brutality
if you haven't been elected to office
are you allowed to criticize congress
they're not making a real argument
they're trying to silence dissent
not playing along sorry every american
citizen has a right
maybe an obligation to know what the
military they pay for
is doing because our lives may depend on
it
today the department of defense launched
a large and coordinated public relations
offensive against this show
pentagon brass issued hostile statements
people in uniform sent out videos on
social media
the dod even issued a news release
attacking
us press secretary smite's fox news host
smites like we're a hostile foreign
power
we suspect this is one war they might
actually win they've got a
manpower advantage we could pull you a
lot of tape from this today it took up
most of their day and we could marvel
over it
since when does the pentagon declare war
on a domestic
news operation i can't remember that
ever happening
but we're not going to do that we're
going to pass because this is bigger
than
a feud with some flack at the pentagon
this is genuinely worrisome the
department of defense
has never been more aggressively or
openly political
tonight there are 2500 american troops
stationed in afghanistan and they remain
there to prevent the fall of kabul to
extremists
at the same time there are 5 000 troops
in our own capital tonight
also as protection against extremists
meaning people who voted for the losing
candidate in the last election
judging by those numbers the pentagon is
now twice as focused on controlling our
own citizens
as it is on controlling the taliban
meanwhile as lloyd austin
hyperventilates about white supremacy
there are real threats out there and the
biggest ones continue to be ignored
those threats are not syria they're not
suburban virginia
they're not domestic extremism at least
right now
the main threat that we face and
everyone who is honest knows this
is the government of china china is
ascendant
their economy will soon outpace ours
china now has the largest navy on the
planet
why do they have that why did they feel
the need to build it
does that have potential consequences
for us
yes if china moved against taiwan
how exactly would we respond more likely
if the chinese decided to close
international shipping lanes it would
[ __ ] our economy
if they decide to shut down our internet
it would bring our life to a halt
if it decided to occupy malaysia that
would be a grave concern to the world
if any of these things happen or a
hundred other things that might happen
what exactly would our pentagon do about
it
can the u.s military still win a real
war
those are the questions that matter
those are the only
questions that matter which may be why
joe biden wants to talk about maternity
flight suits